hey 42 here if you've ever moved to a
new town or city you'll know how
difficult it can be to make friends
traditional advice is to sign up to some
kind of group or Club where you can meet
like-minded people you could take a
pottery class join a wine Appreciation
Society or become a member of the local
Glee Club I for one have made lifelong
friends in the Illuminati if you're the
more adventurous type though you might
consider joining aspiring a secret click
of agents who live under false
identities and meeting clandestine
locations to exchange top secret
information and tips on the latest
disguises one man who took this route
was William siebold a German American
who in 1940 joined what would become the
biggest spy ring in U.S history
seabelt had recently returned to America
after a couple of years in his native
country of Germany but if you'd met him
in those days he would have introduced
himself as Harry Sawyer a diesel
engineer that Alias had been given to
him by the Gestapo he'd cornered sibal
during his visit to Germany and politely
encouraged him to begin spying on his
adopted Nation the United States as most
people did after a chat with a bunch of
high-ranking Nazis threatening to murder
their entire family siebold agreed over
the following few weeks he was trained
in his Newfound profession before being
shipped back to the states to begin
collecting Intelligence on behalf of the
Fiora what Hitler and his cronies didn't
know though was that seabold had no
intention of doing their bidding whilst
being trained in Germany he visited the
American Consulate in Cologne in secret
explaining his situation and offerings
become a double agent working with the
FBI
when siebelt returned to New York in
February 1940 the FBI helped him set up
a new life as Harry Sawyer including
office space where he'd carry out his
work as an engineer or at least that was
the cover Story the real purpose of the
premises was to act as a meeting place
for siebold and other German spies the
officers were rigged with hidden cameras
and microphones and it was seabold's job
to get his fellow spies talking with the
FBI watching and listening in sibo
didn't know it at the time but the
clandestine operation was about to bring
him face to face with one of the most
accomplished spies and all-around
interesting people in history his name
was Frederick or Fritz Juba Dukan
and he was pretty much the leading
German spy operating in the U.S at the
time spying on the Americans was one of
the final assignments in what was a
truly remarkable life
seriously this guy makes James Bond look
like a stamp collecting geography
teacher if you Google Fritz jubair Ducan
many of the images you will find are of
a man wearing different hats literally
but Fritz wore many metaphorical hats
too including South African boar con man
journalist movie publicist Big Game
Hunter German Soldier British army
officer fictitious Australian war hero
hippo salesman hunting adviser to
President Roosevelt and of course spy
yes that list did include hippo salesman
can you imagine the ads only one owner
runs well low mileage a real head turner
but a bit heavy on fuel and handling can
be a bugger in the course of his rich
and colorful life Duquesne went by many
names and aliases at one point he even
assumed the identity of a real-life
Russian Duke that's why he's referred to
as the Duke in FBI fails but other
military code names included Dunn and
the Black Panther he fought in multiple
wars being caught and imprisoned six
times and sentenced to death at least
once but he escaped every single time
duken was born in 1877 into a boar
family in South Africa the boss being a
nation of pioneers and farmers who left
the cape colony of South Africa where
European settlement began and migrated
to settle in the interior of the South
African Wilderness his family lived on a
farm in the middle of nowhere and Jung
Fritz became a hunter like his father
at the clearly not so tender age of 12.
duken killed Zulu tribesmen who'd
attacked his mother with the tribesman's
own spear having displayed such powerful
survival instincts Fritz was apparently
judged to be ready for school in England
which is where he went next like so much
of his later life details of what duken
did after school are sketchy but we do
know that he returned to his homeland at
the turn of the 20th century to fight
against the British in the second Boer
War one of his missions was to deliver a
shipment of gold to a port in what is
present-day Mozambique this Precious
Cargo was being sent to a group of
exiled boars including then president of
South Africa Paul Kruger an argument
broke out amongst the boars escorting
Duquesne shipment and soon blows were
being traded when the dust settled only
Duquesne two wounded boars and some low
local Porters were left alive rumor has
it that Fritz finished off the two
remaining boars ordered the porters to
torch the wagons and hid the gold in a
cave before riding off into the sunset
on an ox as you do
to this day the missing gold has never
been recovered so if you're looking for
a dramatic career change and happen to
own a metal detector maybe mozambique's
the place to go during the course of the
war Duquesne was captured three times by
the British and three times he escaped
when he and his men were treated to
Portuguese East Africa he was captured
by the Portuguese too and imprisoned
near Lisbon again he escaped before
finding his way to England where with a
false ID and presumably a ridiculous
accent he enlisted as an officer in the
British army by 1901 he was on his way
back to South Africa once there he
discovered that his family farm had been
raised to the ground in line with the
scorched Earth policy implemented by the
British leader Lord Kitchener Dukan
learned his mother had been put into a
concentration camp whilst his sister had
been raped and murdered by British
soldiers Fritz was unsurprisingly not
best pleased with this turn of events
and so he and 19 accomplices conspired
to exact their Revenge by assassinating
Lord Kitchener but before they had the
chance to carry out their plan they were
sold out by one of the conspirators
wives all 20 men were sentenced to death
by firing squad but Fritz literally
dodged a bullet when he offered to
reveal bore military codes in exchange
for a stay of execution his reward was a
life sentence in the ironically named
castle of Good Hope in Cape Town where
he attempted to escape using the
time-honored spoon-digging technique he
almost made it too but when his plan
failed he was sent to serve the rest of
his sentence in a jail in Bermuda Fritz
soon added that prison to his list of
Great Escapes when he scaled a barbed
wire fence swam almost two and a half
kilometers through shark-ridden seas and
avoided Patrol boats and searchlights on
his way to safety from there he traveled
to the USA where he would settle never
to return to South Africa in America
Ducane supported himself as a journalist
even writing several novels before being
recruited as an expert on African
Wildlife by a congressman trying to
address the national meat shortage by
passing the American hippo bill of 1911
which aims to introduce hippo meat as a
staple of the American diet the New York
Times tried to dress things up a bit by
calling hippo meat Lake cow bacon but in
the end the bill wasn't passed so
Americans never got a chance to find out
just how good or bad the lcblt
sandwiches might have been it was around
this time that Ducane became acquainted
with Theodore Roosevelt joining the
American president on a hunting Safari
in East Africa as his personal shooting
instructor in 1913 duken became a
naturalized American citizen so it
seemed he was a Yankee through and
through but as anyone who's spoken to a
pretty girl in Thailand will tell you
things aren't always what they seem when
war broke out in 1914 Fritz lived up to
his name and became a German spy working
in South America he sank 22 British
Merchant ships by planting bombs in
their cargo holds when British
intelligence caught on to him he fled to
Argentina and attempted to fake his own
death by publishing an article in a
local newspaper describing his murder at
the hands of Amazonian tribes people in
Bolivia
when the heat had died down he slipped
past British intelligence and returned
to New York in May 1916 using an assumed
identity showing a pair of balls as big
as melons Duquesne had insured cargo on
the very ships he'd blown up when they
sank as he obviously knew they would
seeing because he was the one who
planted the bombs he tried to claim on
the insurance but when the insurance
company finished an investigation into
the whole Affair Fritz was arrested on
fraud that was 1917 and Duquesne was
making money on the lecture circuit
pretending to be a decorated Australian
war hero called Captain stalkton he
claimed to have seen more war than
anyone around and to have survived being
bayonetted three times gassed for and
stuck with a hook once but not even
Crocodile Dundee could escape the
clutches of an insurance company and
eventually Fritz was napped for his
crimes to make things worse when he was
arrested the authorities found damning
evidence linking him to the cargo ship
bombings the British were Keen to
prosecute him and Duquesne was set to be
extradited to the UK to face serious
charges but showing an unbelievable
amount of patience resourcefulness and
some great acting Duquesne pulled off
yet another great escape he feigned
paralysis in his right leg for two years
convincing both his jailers and doctors
that he was truly lame as a result Fritz
was sent to the prison ward of Bellevue
Hospital and from there he escaped
dressed as a woman just a few days
before his scheduled extradition duken
went to ground in Mexico and later
Europe but returned to New York in 1926
with yet another identity and a new
career as a movie publicist he is good
at it too even doing some work for
Joseph Kennedy the father of JFK but
that success came at a price Ducane was
a notorious criminal wanted by the
police and the more well-known he became
through his work the greater the chances
of someone recognizing him it took six
years but eventually someone realized
who deken really was and alerted the FBI
he was arrested again but this time
released on a technicality in the
mid-1930s with another War looming frit
was approached by German intelligence
and got to building a spy ring that
would eventually number more than 30
operatives these agents were mostly made
up of low profile types who infiltrated
many different Industries including
Aviation engineering and shipping and
they provided invaluable information to
the German leadership by this time dukem
was extremely experienced and was known
to be very careful about being followed
and observed but even he didn't see the
Trap that had been laid for him by the
FBI and the man we met at the start of
the story William siebold AKA Harry
Sawyer when the men first met duken he
was cagey but just like the rest of the
Nazi spies in his Circle he eventually
revealed all kinds of Secrets and
sensitive information in seabold's
camera rigged office
the FBI meticulously filmed recorded and
investigated aspiring for two years
building up a rock-solid case and in
June 1941 the FBI arrested Duquesne and
32 German spies in the largest
ever-american Espionage case that led to
convictions
19 of the operatives pleaded guilty
immediately and 14 were convicted later
the group received over 300 years of
jail time between them with Fritz
earning 18 of his own there was no
Escape for dukeen this time and he
served 14 years of his term before being
released on grounds of ailing Health he
would deliver his final public talk
titled my life in and out of prison at
the adventurers Club in New York in 1954
before passing away two years later at
the age of 77 with a life so full of
goods Glory crime and intrigue who knows
what he would have chosen to include in
that speech but I like to think hippos
got a mention
thanks for watching